it is increasingly clear that Donald
Trump has started to stoke fears and
make threats that are getting us in the
direction of a military engagement some
would call it a war colloquially with
the country of Iran Donald Trump has
started talking about the Iran ballistic
missiles test of a week ago yesterday
Sunday the Trump administration has
placed sanctions on Iran UN ambassador
nikki Haley sorry it's hard for me to
actually say that and not feel a little
bit ill the United Nations ambassador
nikki Haley said this is absolutely
unacceptable we will act accordingly we
will be loud about the Iran ballistic
missile test Iran says that the test was
for defensive purposes the US Defense
Department says that the test failed
exploding after traveling for 630 miles
and that it doesn't really pose a threat
to the United States or any of its
allies National Security Advisor Michael
Flynn and press secretary Sean Spicer
say that the test violates the u.s.
'iron nuclear deal and the UN resolution
endorsing it iraq's defense minister
says that actually the test I'm sorry
Iran's defense minister says that the
test does not violate the nuclear deal
or UN resolutions did it violate the
deal but more importantly if you're
against the deal anyway does it matter
if it violates the deal I don't know
most analysts say that this test did
violate the spirit of the deal but did
not technically violate the deal because
the UN resolution says that Iran is
called upon not to undertake activity
related to ballistic missiles but it
doesn't say that they shall not or are
barred from participating in such tests
so Iran was ignoring the advice of the
UN related to the UN the u.s. Iran
nuclear deal but not really denying or
defying a specific directive Obama
actually fought for stronger wording but
Russia and China and even some of our
European allies didn't want it Iran says
we didn't violate it especially because
the missile is
designed to carry a warhead so the crux
of this now is that trumps challenge is
to contain the Iran missile program but
he's got to sort of be diplomatic and
cordial enough that Iran will continue
on honoring the nuclear deal to the
extent that Donald Trump is going to
keep it and we still don't know whether
he is or isn't so what does Donald Trump
do maybe not surprisingly he gets on
Twitter at 3:30 4:00 a.m. in the morning
and says quote Iran has been formally
put on notice for firing a ballistic
missile should have been thankful for a
terrible deal the u.s. made with them
and then at 3 a.m. on Friday morning
3:28 a.m. on Friday morning adding on
Twitter
Iran is playing with fire they don't
appreciate how quote kind President
Obama was to them not me this is what
the left said Trump would do when the
left was being sort of hyperbolic or
tongue in cheek right Trump is going to
make diplomatic proclamations to hostile
nations at 3:00 a.m. in the morning at
3:00 a.m. on Twitter it's not a joke
it's actually happening that was a joke
during the campaign Trump is actually
going on Twitter and threatening
countries in the middle of the night
iran's Foreign Minister says that they
are unmoved by the Twitter threats from
the middle of the night with Donald
Trump it wasn't the middle of the night
in Iran so I guess for them it was a
good time to be checking out what Trump
is tweeting I'm not looking to defend
Iran here
Iran has an ego problem here they're
constantly belittled and cornered and we
need to sort of acknowledge that and act
intelligently Iran is looking for
excuses to pull out of the deal and
violate the u.s. Iran nuclear deal how
insane is it when the president is
destroying the little diplomatic
relations that exist and I used that
term colloquially on Twitter at 3:28 and
3:30 4:00 a.m. the guy nicknamed Mad Dog
here Mad Dog Madison to be the least
belligerent and you know that you're
really out on a limb when the guy you
hired who's called Mad Dog
is actually the voice of reason
everything is backwards folks it's
absolutely unbelievable